JEFFREY EISENACH: Welcome, everyone, to AEI.
My name is Jeff Eisenach.
I’m a visiting scholar here, and I’m delighted
to welcome everyone to today’s discussion
with the European Union’s commissioner for
competition, Margrethe Vestager.
Before introducing Commissioner Vestager,
I’d like to note that we have probably several
luminaries in the room today, but, in particular,
Ambassador of the European Union to the United
States David O’Sullivan is here.
I wanted to welcome Ambassador O’Sullivan
and thank him for being here.
On a procedural note, our program will begin
today with remarks from Commissioner Vestager.
After that, she’s agreed to take some questions.
I’ll ask the first few, and then we will
open it up to the audience.
When we do, we’ll ask that you wait for
the microphone and that you state your name
and your affiliation before asking your question.
Now, it’s a great honor for us to have Commissioner
Vestager with us today.
She’s a native of Denmark and has served
in very senior positions in the Danish government,
including as minister of education from 1998
through 2001, minister for economic affairs
in the interior from 2011 to 2014.
She was political leader of the Danish Social
Liberal Party.
Ambassador O’Sullivan and I were talking
about those words have somewhat different
meanings in Denmark maybe than they do here.
But she was political leader of the Danish
Social Liberal Party from 2007 to 2014.
And it’s my understanding that she has served
as the role model for the protagonist of a
popular Danish television series about the
election of the country’s first female prime
minister.
So she’s not prime minister, but someone
plays one based on her on television.
In Brussels, she served as president of the
Economic and Financial Council, also known
as ECOFIN, in 2011, and in October 2014, she
was confirmed by the European Parliament as
commissioner for competition.
Since then, she has been responsible for some
of the largest and most significant antitrust
actions in the history of the European Union.
Well, not all of these, and indeed, the majority
have not involved US companies.
Certainly the ones that have gotten the most
attention on this side of the Atlantic have,
including the abuse of dominance finding against
Google earlier this year, resulting in a fine,
the largest antitrust fine in European Union
history of $2.7 billion.
And her 2016 finding that Ireland’s tax
treatment of Apple has violated the EU’s
prohibitions against state aid, meaning that
Apple owes currently $14 billion in back taxes.
Actions like these have won praise from some
and criticism from others.
Here at AEI, we are committed to free enterprise
and competitive markets, including competition
in the marketplace of ideas.
And with that in mind, it’s an honor to
welcome Commissioner Vestager to the American
Enterprise Institute.
We look forward to your remarks.
(Applause.)
MARGRETHE VESTAGER: Ladies and gentlemen,
it is a — it’s a great pleasure to be
here.
And I knew I’d feel welcome, and it’s
not only because of the very sort of Danish
way my name was pronounced, which is actually
quite rare, I can tell you this.
But also that this institute has a motto:
The competition of ideas is fundamental to
a free society.
And for me, this is what policymaking is all
about.
If our ideas are never challenged, they’ll
never get any better.
We end up stuck with ideas that once served
us well but haven’t kept up with changes
in our world and our societies.
And when we don’t hear different views,
well, I think also we lose the freedom to
think for ourselves.
And just as competition of ideas is fundamental
to a free society, competition in our markets
is fundamental to a fair one because challenges
and competition makes us better.
If businesses are not challenged, if they
don’t have to compete, well, they don’t
have any reason to work better to serve people
better.
Competition is that motor that actually drives
businesses to do better for consumers, to
cut prices, to offer more choice, to produce
innovative products.
Competition enforcers didn’t build that
motor.
We just help to keep it running, running smoothly
by getting rid of the obstacles that may stop
competition from doing its work.
And this is why antitrust rules prevent cartels,
stop dominant companies misusing their powers
to drive out competitors.
This is why we have rules to make sure that
mergers do not undermine competition.
And this is also why, now, more than 60 years
ago, when the European Union was founded,
we were given rules on state aid to stop governments
using subsidies to give some companies an
unfair benefit and, therefore, unravel the
level playing field.
The most basic aim of competition rules is
that of keeping prices down.
In the past five years, more than half of
antitrust decisions has been about putting
a stop to cartels, like our decision last
year to fine five European truck makers a
total of nearly three billion euros for a
cartel that fixed gross list prices of trucks
for 14 years.
Most of our work on mergers is also about
keeping prices down.
In more than
90 percent of the mergers that we have to
step into, the last year and the year before,
our main concerns were that the merger would
have meant fewer competitors and higher prices.
And that makes a real difference.
In those two years, our estimate is that the
work on mergers and cartels has saved customers
as much as 30 billion euros.
And that is without ever considering the mergers
that were never filed or the cartels that
were never formed because our rules wouldn’t
have allowed for it.
But there is more to competition than keeping
prices down.
Even when a product seems to be free, like
a search engine or a social network, competition
still helps to get consumers a better deal.
Last year, we looked at Microsoft’s merger
with LinkedIn.
And even though most people used LinkedIn
without paying for it, at least in cash, we
were concerned that the merger would affect
competition.
We knew that after the merger, the two companies
would connect their products.
And that would have risked shutting down other
professional social networks of the European
market.
Without competition, the user would have lost
choice.
They could have lost, for example, the chance
to choose another service or a service with
the best privacy policy.
So we only approved the merger after Microsoft
gave us commitment that it would keep the
market open also after the merger.
Competition gives us more choice and lower
prices today, but it also helps us to get
better products tomorrow because competition,
the drive to get ahead of your competitors,
that pushes businesses to keep innovating.
Earlier this year, we found that the merger
between Dow and DuPont would not just raise
prices but also hold back innovation.
Dow and DuPont were two of just five companies
that took part in all stages of developing
pesticides to meet the needs of farmers throughout
the world.
And we found evidence that they planned to
cut back on their research after the merger.
That would have slowed innovation.
It would have left farmers stuck with older
products that may have been less effective
and more toxic.
So we only approved the merger after companies
agreed to sell a large part of DuPont’s
pesticide business, including the worldwide
research arm for pesticides.
Innovation was also an issue in our decision
against Google earlier this year.
Consumers don’t pay to use Google’s search
engine, not in cash at least.
But that doesn’t change the fact that search
of the internet is a market, and it is one
in which Google is dominant in Europe, with
more than 90 percent market share in most
European countries.
Market dominance gives a special responsibility
— a special responsibility under European
competition law.
And this is a responsibility not to abuse
the power but to keep competition only on
the merits of products and services.
And in our decision, we established that Google
did not comply with this obligation.
Instead, Google decided to use its power as
a search engine to deny other companies a
chance to compete on neighboring markets — namely,
the market for shopping comparison.
Google showed its own comparison shopping
service at the very top of the first page
of search results, and that gave its own services
a prominence that its competitors couldn’t
match.
Google also demoted its rival services in
search results so that they only appeared
on average on page four.
And just go through your recent behavior when
you have done a search on the internet.
How often did you get to page four?
I see no raised hands.
The results were effective, impressive.
Google’s rivals suddenly lost as much as
90 percent of their traffic.
And despite their best efforts, they never
got all these visitors back.
And that matters not because we feel sorry
for those competitors.
After all, for competition to do its job,
well, companies have to be able to lose as
well as win.
But that cuts both ways.
Big companies also have to face competition,
to face the risk of failure, and that won’t
happen if we allow them to use their power
to stop anyone else from having the chance
to compete.
Because when companies can’t lose, they
cannot do better either.
Of course, and this is obvious — I’m sorry
to waste your time saying this — it is not
the job of a competition authority to take
the place of the markets to set the prices
of trucks, to tell Google or Dow that innovation
is important and what it can produce.
But we know that as long as competition stays
fierce, those companies will have no choice
but to meet consumers’ needs, to keep prices
low, to make an effort to innovate.
And there is no need for us to interfere in
that process by trying to say precisely what
should be the outcome of competition.
But there are times when public authorities
as such need to go further, when it does make
sense to control what the market produces,
when our health or our environment or our
basic rights are in question.
These are important concerns, but they’re
not something that competition rules can fix
— not because there is a problem with our
competition rules, but because competition
is only part of the answer.
Look at pesticides, for example.
Farmers, they need affordable, innovative
pesticides, and competitive markets can answer
that.
So by protecting competition, our decisions
on the mergers between Dow and DuPont will
keep prices down and innovation thriving.
And we will take the same approach when we
look at the merger — the planned merger
between Bayer and Monsanto.
But prices and innovation are not the only
things that matter.
I’ve had many letters, postcards, emails,
tweets from people who are concerned about
these chemical mergers.
Sometimes they worry about prices and innovation,
but ever so often they are worried about what
pesticides can do to the environment or to
our health or the safety of our food.
And I agree that we cannot just rely on the
market to guarantee that pesticides are safe
for the farmers, for environment, for us as
consumers.
We need the protection of clear and strict
regulation.
Europe has some of the world’s most stringent
pesticide regulations in the world.
Those regulations applied before the mergers,
and they will still apply after the mergers,
no matter what form they may be completed
in, both to the companies that merge and to
companies that do not merge.
But we shouldn’t mix things up.
My job as a European commissioner for competition
is to look at how a merger will affect exactly
competition, and that is what I will do with
my teams.
Controlling vehicle emissions is another case
where competition law enforcement is not enough.
Understandably, many people are concerned
about how their lifestyle affects the environment.
And through the market, they can put a lot
of pressure on companies to innovate and to
produce greener products.
And if companies sort of answer or respond
to that pressure by working together to resist
the demand for greener products, then competition
enforcers may have to step in.
And that’s what happened in this truck-makers
cartel I just told you about because the other
side of it was not only the coordination of
gross list prices.
It was also that its
members coordinated the introduction of greener
technology so that none of them would bring
the new technology to the market before they
were forced to do that.
But we cannot just rely on the markets to
protect the environment.
We still need rules for vehicle emissions
that protect our health and our climate.
And we need regulators who can punish companies
that break those rules — but it is for them.
Competition and enforcement is a bit of a
paradox.
Our job is to help markets work better and
more freely.
But to do that, we need to interfere in the
market, and that is, of course, a paradox.
And it makes the work a delicate balance.
We shouldn’t step in when competition is
not really threatened.
We shouldn’t block a merger, for example,
that would cut costs for consumers, but it
is just as important that we do not look away
when we see something happening that does
harm competition.
Either way, if we get it wrong, consumers
will suffer.
So what can we do?
And this will be the end, because I would
like, of course, to make a bow because I think
the good thing to do is to look at the motto
of this institute by making sure that also
our ideas of competition are open to competition.
We can exchange ideas with experts both in
Europe and further away.
And, in fact, we do just that all the time.
We do it through organizations like the International
Competition Network, which brings together
more than 100 authorities from all over the
world, including the Federal Trade Commission
and Department of Justice.
And that network helps us to discuss some
of the trickiest issues of competition enforcement,
and it helps us to reach common ground as
we did in 2014, as an example, when we agreed
on recommended practices on predatory pricing.
We also exchange ideas about cases.
Since the start last year, we worked with
US authorities on more than 20 different mergers,
like the merger between AB InBev and SABMiller,
the world’s two largest beer brewers, or
the ChemChina takeover of Sygenta.
We’ve discussed things like how these mergers
might harm consumers and what could be done
better to restore competition.
And that collaboration and those discussions
have helped us to protect consumers better.
Being open to new ideas is maybe more important
now than ever because our markets are going
through enormous changes.
Some of those changes are about technology.
Algorithms are taking over decisions from
people, including decisions on the prices
that companies charge.
Big data is also a big helper to cut costs
and improve services, which could mean that
companies without that data struggle to compete.
Meanwhile, some markets are showing signs
of becoming more concentrated, with fewer,
bigger companies, even if so far in Europe
those signs are limited to a few industries
in certain countries.
So we need to discuss these issues now, when
we can still adapt.
And that is why I’m looking to set up a
panel of experts from outside the commission
to advise us on how these
changes will affect consumers and how competition
enforcement should respond.
Because even though our world is changing,
I think it is clear that competition rules
still matter.
For many, many years to come, competitive
markets will still be the best way to meet
consumers’ needs — low prices, wide choice,
innovative products for tomorrow.
And to make sure that markets work, we need
competition rules to be enforced.
Applying those rules in practice won’t get
any easier, but we don’t have a choice.
Competition in the market is as fundamental
to a fair society as competition of ideas
is to a free one.
And I think that is as true today as it has
ever been.
Thank you.
(Applause.)
DR.
EISENACH: Well, you’ve covered a lot of
ground, and I want to spend a couple of minutes
just drilling down on some of these current
antitrust issues.
And let me start with a quote, kind of very
famous in American antitrust jurisprudence
from I think the judge with the best name
of all time, Learned Hand.
Somehow never made it on the Supreme Court,
but Judge Hand, a very famous Appeals Court
judge, wrote that it was very important that
antitrust not punish the successful competitor,
the firm which by virtue of its expertise,
its hard work, its entrepreneurship is successful
in capturing the market.
And, as Judge Hand said, the successful competitor,
having been urged to compete, must not be
turned upon when he wins.
So as you think about the problem — that’s
an old quote, and this is an old problem.
That’s a quote from 1945 — as you think
about that and you think the Googles of the
world and the Facebooks of the world who unquestionably
have won the race, how do you distinguish
between conduct which is harmful to consumers
and harmful to competition as opposed to conduct
which is simply harming the unsuccessful,
the less — the firms producing less value,
who haven’t been as entrepreneurial or successful
in the race?
MS.
VESTAGER: Well, this is exactly the balance,
to make sure that you get the right distinctions.
In Europe, we have no ban on monopolies.
You’re more than welcome to grow one yourself.
You can’t buy one, but you can grow one.
If you have products that people like, and
they keep coming, then you can keep growing.
The only thing is that when you then because
of the virtues of your products become dominant,
then you get a special responsibility because
it is quite obvious that competition suffers
if you yourself hold like 90 percent of the
market.
So you get this responsibility not to misuse
your muscle.
And this is exactly the thing.
You can grow.
You can grow big.
We will congratulate you all the way, but
the congratulation stops if we find that you
start misusing your position.
And this is, of course, what will have to
be tested on in courts because this is exactly
the case of the Google case.
DR.
EISENACH: Also the Intel case.
So last week — in 2009, the commission found
Intel in violation of the abuse of dominance
rules by virtue of giving rebates to some
of its customers in a way that was alleged
to drive out competition.
And last week,
the European Court of Justice remanded that
decision.
It’s been through the courts now in a couple
of rounds of appeal, remanded the decision
back to a lower court.
And as I read, fully read the decision, but
as I understand it, on the grounds that neither
the commission nor the lower courts had given
sufficient account to the question of whether
Intel’s conduct would harm an equally efficient
competitor.
So that’s a standard which is very much
part of American jurisprudence.
Do you see that decision having an effect
on — first of all, how do you see that decision
as it affects the Intel matter, to the extent
you can talk about it?
And then, do you see that decision affecting
other matters underway, Google, Colcom, and
so forth?
MS.
VESTAGER: Well, it’s hard to have an opinion
on something that is undecided.
DR.
EISENACH: Right.
MS.
VESTAGER: Because, basically, the European
Court of Justice sets the general court, you
have to redo your work.
You have to look into the substance once again,
and the rest of us will have to, of course,
respectfully wait and see what comes out of
this.
In the meantime, obviously, we have work to
do, and we have also of course developed working
methods and lines of thinking since the Intel
decision back in 2009.
So we will keep working our cases.
And I think it is important also to recognize
that most cases, they will be looked at from
both sides — from the sides of what’s
the effect and what’s the objects of the
behavior.
The two other respects of the case — the
one of jurisdiction was a very clear win for
the commission, and the third one will sort
of keep us in sort of thinking mode for some
time because it was a question of how a meeting
with a witness was being recorded.
It had no influence on the concrete case.
We have changed procedures since then, but
the court still gave us guidance as how to
do this looking forward, and that, of course,
we will respect and try to follow that guidance.
DR.
EISENACH: OK.
So I’m sure there are real limits on what
you want to say or can’t say but just with
respect to Google because, obviously, there’s
a lot of interest.
I think we have not had the full written decision
released yet, unless it’s been very recent.
So when will we see — because there are
a lot of people looking forward to reading
it.
And then, just for people who are not following
this as closely, maybe can you talk a little
bit about the concerns with Android and AdSense
and what those investigations can do?
MS.
VESTAGER: Yeah.
We really do our best to try to make our decisions
public as fast as possible.
But that, of course, had to respect that there
can be concerns of business confidentiality
so we have to clear the decisions first.
And that takes the time it takes.
But that we make a priority after the decision
has been taken because, as you say, lots of
people would like to read the decisions in
full, as full as they can be when we have
redacted some of the most confidentiality
concerned issues.
You have a very difficult language.
You realize that?
(Laughter.)
I have a number of words, I try to avoid them,
but, well, anyway.
The two other cases are very different.
The AdSense case is a case about placement
of ads on third-party sites.
What can you make out of demands, how this
can be worked for people also want to enter
this market of placing ads on third-party
websites.
The Android case may be more interesting because
it has to do with dominance and search when
we all go mobile because this is, of course,
the only thing that is growing and growing
very, very fast.
We all become mobile.
We have our smartphones, tablets, smaller
screens.
And in the statement of objection, what we’re
saying is that, as we see it, Google has been
using Android, which is a very interesting
operating system.
It’s open source — lots of amazing things
can be said about that.
But it has been used to make sure that when
you open your box, then you have the Google
experience on your smartphone.
And now, of course, we’re in the process
of going through the Google defense on the
statement of objection, and eventually we
will come to a decision.
DR.
EISENACH: OK.
One distinction — or at least I think a
lot of Americans perceive a distinction between
US enforcement and in the EU.
I think this applies both to mergers and maybe
especially abuse of dominance — is the role
of competitors.
So it’s certainly the case that competitors
will show up with complaints before the Federal
Trade Commission and the Department of Justice.
But I guess at least the perception is that
they receive a friendlier hearing when they
show up in front of DigComp in Brussels.
Do you share that perception?
Do you think that European antitrust jurisprudence
is less skeptical or gives more weight to
competitor complaints than in the United States?
And if so, do you think that’s a good thing
or a bad thing?
MS.
VESTAGER: Well, I don’t think our courts
have this bias, and since they don’t have
the bias, we don’t have the bias.
Because our decisions, they go to court almost
with no exception — a few, but almost with
no exception.
So we have to prepare to be heard in court.
And what court wants is, of course, the jurisprudence,
is the evidence, the fact of the case.
They don’t want to hear any sort of soft
feelings, and oh, we feel sorry for you.
It has no place in a courtroom.
So, yes, of course it’s a source of information,
of concern to get a case started, but it’s
not the case of the competitor.
It is what happens to the consumer, if this
behavior can actually be proven with the evidence
of the case.
And this is what we do, and I don’t think
there’s any problem in listening to complainants,
taking on board the evidence they come with.
It’s our responsibility to make sure that
we get the evidence right.
DR.
EISENACH: Well, you mentioned consumer welfare,
and this is my last question or next to last.
You know, we live in obviously very challenging
times, times of tremendous change, political
change both in the US and the EU.
Brexit and the EU, the Trump election
obviously are signs of turmoil in the United
States.
And the sense that big business or high tech
has not produced the kind of benefits that
people would have liked to have seen or at
least they haven’t been shared fairly across
society has led to calls on both sides of
the Atlantic for competition to play a more
active role in remediating those problems.
You know, you said in talking about the Apple
decision, I think, that part of the motivation
there was that Europeans were angry, I think
was the word you used about what’s happened,
and about the role playing by kind of big
high-tech companies earning billions in profits
and not playing taxes.
In the US, we’ve had this phenomenon of
what some people have referred to as hipster
antitrust, the notion that antitrust ought
to expand.
And some of our, we call them progressives
here, senators, have, you know, come up with
the notion that antitrust ought to play a
much broader role in kind of pursuing social
justice.
So I read some of the things you’d written
previously, and you spoke to this issue from
the podium here, taught in that — and I
apologize for the broad question — but in
that kind of broad context, you know, how
do you see the limits of antitrust?
How far can antitrust go to helping to pursue
these kind of social justice objectives, and
what are the hard limits where it just needs
to step back to say, that’s not ours to
solve?
MS.
VESTAGER: Well, for us, we are obliged by
our laws, by our treaty, and those political
choices were taken a long, long time ago,
60 years ago.
And this is our mandate.
And I think it is very, very important to
stick to that mandate because even though
a lot of competence is with the European Commission,
it’s a very powerful tool.
I think anyone who has been doing a little
do-it-yourself knows that just because you
have a wonderful hammer, not everything is
a nail.
I know firsthand from — you wouldn’t want
to see my walls.
So you definitely have to know the limitations
of antitrust because there are democratically
elected institutions who have their responsibility.
And I think it’s a good thing because otherwise
you completely delegitimize what we do in
our analytical work in mergers, in a cartel
investigation, looking into a case of misuse
of dominant position, if we start to pour
other things down that pot.
And that I think is important.
And the other thing is that we also try to
be precise to say, well, when we take a decision,
it’s about a certain behavior, a certain
behavior that may be illegal because most
companies also have produced wonderful things.
I can remember what it was like to try to
find something on the internet before we had
search engines.
You could hardly try because you had to get
the full address completely right, otherwise
just forget about it.
The innovation produced by some of the companies,
well, they have changed our societies.
They have changed our lives.
These are amazing innovations.
And this is why they are successful.
I think if you would ask any European, why
do you Google things?
Why do you have a Facebook account?
They’d say, it works.
It’s wonderful.
I like it.
They would never come up with the answer that
it’s because it’s an American company.
DR.
EISENACH: Well, thank you for all of those
great answers.
And now we do have an opportunity for the
audience.
I think the first hand I saw was right here.
Wait for a microphone.
It’s on its way.
And introduce yourself, please.
Q: Hello, Commissioner.
My name is Don Baker (sp).
I’m a former — spent 10 years in antitrust
enforcement at the Justice Department.
And I wanted to ask you about these fines.
In other words, we in this country tend to
look at big fines as something that we impose
on conduct that’s unmitigated — you know,
there’s no justification for it, per se
illegal, and we limit it pretty much to cartel
kind of activity.
In Europe, you’re levying record fines against
conduct that in a way falls more within a
rule of reason — namely, priorities and
things like this.
And, by contrast, in this country, we get
injunctive relief, maybe structural relief
against monopolies, but we don’t hammer
them with big fines.
And I just wondered whether you have any reaction
to that kind of issue
and concern.
MS.
VESTAGER: Well, I never sort of had the line
of thinking that we’re hammering big companies.
We are punishing illegal behavior because
you can be big in Europe — very, very, very
big.
You can grow enormous market shares if consumers
like your products.
And the level of fines recently is more a
reflection of the size of the companies because
we have a set of guidelines to say what to
take into consideration, turnover, duration,
sort of the depth of the illegal behavior.
And that, of course, we follow in order for
people to know what they would get themselves
into if they cartelized a product or misused
a dominant position.
So, obviously, this is important for us.
I don’t know the differences in any detail
between the two jurisdictions, but what I
can see is that even with the differences,
it still allows us to work very closely together.
What is different is treated differently,
but where things are the same, I also do hope
that companies find that they get more or
less the same treatment.
Q: I wasn’t suggesting — (off mic).
MS.
VESTAGER: No, no.
Q: I know fines are turnover based.
MS.
VESTAGER: Yes.
DR.
EISENACH: Can I follow up on that, because
it raises — that’s a fabulous question,
Don.
So we have a way of imposing big fines on
big corporations that violate Section Two.
We do it through private litigations.
I’m reminded that I think — maybe I
have this wrong — but I think someone won
$4 billion in the Microsoft case as a result
of private litigation, follow-on litigation
after the government’s prosecution.
So in that context, what is the state of private
antitrust litigation in the European Union,
and the thinking in the context of the Google
matter, for example, presumably some of the
competitors who have been harmed by Google
as found by the commission?
Presumably some of them would be pursuing
litigation.
Where does that stand?
Because it’s never been as big a factor
in the EU as it has been in the US.
MS.
VESTAGER: No.
It hasn’t, and it’s only very recently
that our legislation has come into effect
for private damages.
And now, the last member states are just in
the process of making it also national legislation.
We’re seeing sort of the first private damages
sort of coming up, but it’s way too early
to have any kind of prognosis as to how will
this define the future.
The very basic idea — and it was, of course,
by my predecessor, was to say, well, if you
also can go for private damages, the deterrent
effect will be much bigger because we haven’t
had this before, but we’re seeing the effects
in other jurisdictions.
DR.
EISENACH: We had another question here.
Q: Hi.
My name is Matt Miller.
I’m with Capital Group, but we run the American
Fund’s family of Mutual Funds.
And I’m curious — the general privacy
data regulation, which is taking effect I
believe in May in Europe, do you expect that
that will impact the business models of the
large tech firms through what I’ve seen
as discussion of different opt-in or consent
provisions, and how might that impact your
own work in the competition sphere?
Any thoughts on that?
MS.
VESTAGER: Well, as you’re suggesting, this
is not my portfolio.
This is in the hands of my colleague, Vera
Jurova.
But, obviously, this is for us very important.
A lot of work has gone into making new privacy
rules.
They come into effect May next year.
And the main benefit is that you get one set
of rules for the entire European Union.
There are some things that are new — the
right to be forgotten, portability of your
data — but, basically, it sort of creates
the benefit of having one set of rules.
I think to some degree, because my nature
is sort of a glass-half-full nature, it can
be very beneficial because if businesses take
this on board, maybe also to some degree to
offer privacy by design, it can sort of re-create
or reconnect with users.
I think the last time Europeans were asked,
four out of five said we feel that we absolutely
have no control of our personal data.
And I think that poses a risk to all the benefits
that can come from big data.
So if this can be a push to say, well, we
will make it more accessible, more understandable
so that you know what you’re doing and rules
are simpler, you don’t have to relate to
— as a business to 28 different ways of
doing this, then I think it can be beneficial
both on the business side of things and on
the user side of things.
DR.
EISENACH: This gentleman.
Q: My name is Ali Breland.
I’m a reporter with The Hill newspaper.
The question I had was about how White House
officials had reportedly discussed making
companies like Google and Facebook public
utilities.
I was curious to get your take on this argument
and see if you’re amenable to it.
Thanks.
MS.
VESTAGER: We have a very high bar for that.
Public utility or essential facility, as we
would call it, the obvious examples would
be sewers, railroads, the tracks, that kind
of thing because the test would be that it
is not economically doable to do a parallel
structure, that it’s prohibitive in its
nature.
And so far, we have not found that to the
digital part of our economy.
There you still find that, well, some of these
structures and some of these networks, it
is not the economy that prevents you from
doing something similar.
So this is why I think this discussion has
been slightly different in Europe.
DR.
EISENACH: To follow up on that, again, so
there has been discussion about big data as
an essential facility, if I can take those
two words and put them together, and with
the proposal not so much being one of public
utility regulation, but rather mandated sharing
of some sort.
And I think a year or so ago, the commission
issued — had a consultation on some of these
questions.
Where did that come out, and what is the current
thinking on kind of the need for companies,
whether it’s a Google or a Facebook have
unique big-data data sets or arguably, allegedly
unique big-data data sets?
What is the thinking on whether they should
be required under some circumstances to share
those with potential competitors?
MS.
VESTAGER: Well, we try to make things complicated
by saying that you cannot discuss big data
just as big data because there are many, many,
many different kinds of data.
On the one hand side, you have data that is
not to be replicated, that has a very long
duration, that effectively can serve as an
asset that can foreclose competitors from
entering your market.
On the other hand side, you have data which
is easily recollected, the duration is very
short, it’s very open for competitors to
get the same or more data.
And then, of course, you have all complex
situations in between.
We have had a few cases, not with us, but,
for instance, the French National Competition
Authority — they ordered I think what was
their old electricity incumbent, who used
to have a monopoly, to share some of their
customer data with competitors in order to
do sort of add-on sales for those customers
who were buying electricity because you couldn’t
get this data any other way.
But that being said, I think it is very important
to keep this conversation complicated because
otherwise we sort of just close down I think
a lot of the opportunities in data when it
comes to health, transportation, environment,
preventing all kinds of things that we don’t
want in our societies.
But, obviously, we also prepare ourselves
— as I mentioned the Microsoft-LinkedIn
case — to look into these questions also
in some detail to see if the question of data
and the form it takes will be a competition
problem.
DR.
EISENACH: So many hands.
Why don’t we stay in this row?
This is going to be the lucky row today.
Q: Lydia Beyoud.
I’m a reporter with the Event Driven News.
Commissioner, can you give us some more details
on the foreign investment screen that the
commission is considering and whether or not
you think the US’s CFIUS model is something
that could be adopted in Europe?
MS.
VESTAGER: Yes, we have exactly been looking
into other models because we see that the
US has this kind of screening.
I think Canada has it as well.
We find it in Japan.
Some member states already have FDI screening
in different forms.
And I think since world trade and also investment
is developing quite fast these years, as I
see it, it becomes more qualified, more based
on mutual trust and building up relationships
when it comes to different ways of regulating
issues that takes your interest.
But I think it is very important that we have
this element of reciprocity — that if you
can buy things with me, I can buy things with
you.
And it is completely legitimate to say, well,
we would like to have access to consider if
this is not against what we could call public
order.
I know this is a rather broad concept, but,
anyway.
And, for us, it has been important as well,
again, not to sort of just pour it in the
merger analysis part because that would just
complicate things there, but to keep it as
a separate instrument now to be discussed
with member states.
I think the proposal is to be tabled, if it
hasn’t been tabled, very, very recently.
DR.
EISENACH: I think we’ll take one last question,
and we’ll go right here in the front row.
Q: Lou Gagliano, independent consultant.
The question I have is: How do you look at
the contracts that governments give to corporations,
evaluate the question of is that a fair contract
or not given the fact that that government,
whether it’s Ireland or any other member
of the commission?
The European Community has its own responsibility
to manage its own affairs.
So how do you really not step on their kind
of ability to run their own country?
MS.
VESTAGER: Well, we have been looking into
— and this has been going on for quite some
time.
A number of the cases were started with my
predecessor, and part of the work when it
comes to fiscal state aid go all the way back
to Mario Monte.
So it’s a long-standing tradition, and our
courts have said very precisely that we have
a responsibility to control state aid no matter
the form it takes.
It could be cash.
It could be fiscal benefit.
It could be a building lot.
It can be a loan with a very variable interest
rate.
And in the fiscal state aid cases, we’ve
been looking at both schemes but also tax
rulings.
And when we look into the tax rulings, they
are by nature selective because this is for
just one company and then available to anyone
else.
And then, of course, we see, well, does this
give a selective advantage in the way that
things are set up?
And this is our test: Is there selective advantages
here?
The Irish are perfectly welcome to have a
corporate level of taxation of 12.5 percent
as well as Luxembourg are perfectly — it’s
perfectly legal for them to have I think 28.
So you find varied corporate tax rates, but
our test is if it’s for you but not for
everyone else.
Some of the schemes that we have found have
been schemes to say, well, this is for multinationals
only but not for stand-alone businesses, as
the scheme in Belgium.
And, on the other hand side, we have found
schemes in other countries that were set up
to promote national businesses to the disadvantage
of multinational businesses.
And those, of course, we have dealt with as
well and in the same way to say, well, you
cannot do that.
You have to make sure that the way you use
your freedom to do your own taxation that
it’s done with a level playing field.
DR.
EISENACH: We’re going to let that be the
last comment, level playing field.
MS.
VESTAGER: Level playing field, that’s a
beautiful word to put us on.
DR.
EISENACH: Thank you so much for being here.
MS.
VESTAGER: It was a pleasure.
Thank you very much.
(Applause.)